X we're also learning that a judge has
denied ubers settlement with California
drivers this was that 100 million dollar
settlement in the three year old lawsuit
over whether or not drivers should be
treated as employees or independent
contractors and it looks like even
though uber lost the settlement it's
actually good for uber can you explain
what this means I mean what it means is
that uber is is locked in this kind of
ongoing discussion over what its drivers
are are they employees are they
independent contractor sort of small
business men or women and basically what
this settlement means is this this
conversation is going to keep going
which which to be honest even if the
settlement had gone through there would
have been more more issues more court
things more lawsuits etc so it's not
like a huge bit of news but it just does
show like that this is a problem that
Hoover is going to face for for some
time but how does it give over the upper
hand so I suppose it gives you over the
upper hand because what happened in San
Francisco is there a judge wanted wanted
ebers drivers to be able to get out of
arbitration and he was saying he would
not approve the settlement without this
clause that would have allowed them to
get out of arbitration uber said no
we're going to walk away from the deal
if you do that and now that's what's
happening so it means that they won't
have been forced to get to arbitration
situations